pensemos en todas las formas posibles de
representar siete novenos siete a
novenos novenos y bueno seguramente de
una manera visual tú no lo menos
bastante bien así que vamos a hacerlo de
una vez y mediante que yo me tomo aquí
una caja dividida en nueve partes la voy
a poner nosotros por aquí ya esta caja
divide a nueve partes no voy a tomar
siete de ellas por lo tanto vamos a
colorear las si me quiero tomar siete de
ellas y dejarme cambiar la herramienta
no y podré tomar una una de éstas que
dos me pueda tomar dos de estas dos de
éstas
ok poco a poco se van formando las 733
de éstas ok voy formando otra más 44 de
estas partes
otra parte más de 55 me podría fijar
también en esta parte en esta parte de
aquí 6 y 7
necesitamos 2 más así que pongamos las
esta es la 6 ok y por último tengo esta
que es la séptima parte de estas nueve
partes 792 es exactamente lo mismo que
tomar al menos que tomarme siete partes
de esta caja y esto lo estamos viendo
una manera visual ok pero esto ya lo
sabemos muy bien y lo hemos visto en
varios vídeos ahora qué te parece si
nosotros nos tomamos otra forma de ver a
los siete novenos para tomarnos otra
forma de ver a los 79 nos lo que voy a
hacer es descomponer esta fracción en
una suma de fracciones es decir
imagínate que me tomo a dos o más
fracciones evento que a tomarme 3 voy a
tomar aquí entre 9 ya esto le voy a
sumar algo que tenga que ver también con
9 ya esto le voy a sumar algo que tenga
que ver también con
y entonces que me va a quedar de la suma
de estos tres vamos a ver quiénes son
los numeradores y para esto voy a pegar
otra vez otra caja de éstas y la voy a
pegar justo aquí algo muy parecido a
esto
para que tú lo veas de una manera visual
ok ya tengo mi casa dividida en nueve
partes y qué te parece si yo me tomo
primero a dos novenos dos novenos y dos
novenos y tomarme dos partes de esta
caja así que vamos a dibujarlo dos
novenos este va a ser uno de ellos
uno de ellos ok y después me tengo que
tomar otro noveno entonces vamos a
ponerlo esto hace el segundo noveno algo
muy parecido a esto ok ya esto qué te
parece si yo le sumo a se me ocurre tres
novenos le voy a sumar tres no menos más
dos novenos más tres novenos es lo mismo
que cinco novenos vamos a ver si
llegamos lo mismo de que voy a tomar
tres partes de esta caja lo voy a tomar
esta parte de aquí esta va a ser uno de
los tres novenos
en esta parte de aquí ok me agradan y 39
tomar también otra parte de aquí esta
parte de aquí y ya tengo tres novenos
más y date cuenta que ahora tengo 1 2 3
4 5 a lo menos pero todavía no llegamos
a los 7 novenos para llegar a los 7
novenos qué te parece si a esto le
sumamos otros dos novenos de tal manera
que dos más tres más dos es lo mismo que
79 nos íbamos a poner aquí los dos que
me faltan me falta este de aquí y me
falta este de aquí este de aquí también
lo voy a tomar y si te das cuenta
llegamos justo a la misma cantidad de
cuadraditos cuadrados de esta caja que
tengo aquí ahora siete novenos lo
podemos ver como dos novenos más 3 - más
o menos pero también lo puedes componer
de varias maneras distintas que te
parecen que te parece si ahora me tomo
la suma de cuatro fracciones así que
aquí va a ser novenos
otro en nube los 90 parece una más otro
en novenos ya esto le voy a sumar más
otra parte en novenos ok y vamos a hacer
lo mismo de una manera visual así que
déjame tomarme esta cajita de aquí la
voy a poner justo acá ok para que todos
vea si los comparas de una manera visual
y qué te parece si empezamos con 1 - voy
a empezar con un noveno y entonces lo
voy a poner justo aquí un noveno pero un
noveno no es lo mismo que 79 nos falta
bastante para llegar a los 7 novenos así
que qué te parece si ahora le sumó a
otros dos entonces un noveno más dos
novenos son tres novenos vamos a ver
aquí me voy a tomar uno de ellos este de
aquí y no voy a tomar otro este otro de
aquí aunque me voy a tomar estos dos de
aquí ya tengo tres novenos ya esto qué
te parece si le sumamos a se me ocurre 4
cuatro novenos ok pues vamos a poner a
uno más por acá otro más por acá ok
está bastante vacío otro más por acá
otro más por acá tengo este de aquí ok y
me falta uno entonces voy a poner otro
más por acá tengo este más entonces
tengo la suma de 12 + 4 lo cual es un 7
novenos pero habíamos quedado que
nosotros íbamos a poner 4 suman 24
fracciones y por lo tanto que te parece
si a esto le sumamos lo que nos falta
para llegar a 7 novenos lo cual pues ya
no es nada por lo tanto mover a tomar
cero novenos y 0 9o es lo mismo que
decir que me voy a tomar 0 cuadritos de
esta caja por lo tanto no voy a colorear
ningún otro cuadrito no tengo que color
en ninguno y aquí está otra
representación de como descomponer a la
fracción 7 novenos en 4 en la suma de
cuatro fracciones pero puedo tomar 71
menos con la suma de dos tres
4 la cantidad de fracciones que tú
quieras y así descomponerlo